This, to me, looks like
the side of a turtle shell.
This is just pretty incredible.
NARRATOR: On a remote
mountain in the Philippines,
the team is hunting for a
possible tunnel entrance that
could lead to a
fortune in treasure
that the Japanese Army
is believed to have
buried during World War II.
Now they have discovered a rock
that John thinks may have been
carved to resemble a turtle.
I think we have found
what we're looking for.
The tunnel entrance could
be up right under here.
NARRATOR: To verify
the find, John
brings in Peter and Martin.
You look like you've
got something now.
This is the best thing
we've found so far.
This is a turtle.
Yeah, I'm a little
excited now, finally.
[laughs] We're
getting somewhere.
What do turtles
signify anyway?
Well, a turtle can signify
a bunch of different things.
Now, if he's got legs on
him, and they're all even,
and his tail is turned to the
left or right, that's the way
you go.
Now, he's a marker too.
If his head is up and
sitting at an angle,
then out in front of him,
probably within 50 to 100 feet,
will be something buried there.
Of all the things
that we've seen so far,
this really stands out.
We're on the right trail.
This is a really good marker.
Maybe the turtle itself
is not the way to get in.
Maybe that's not the entrance.
The fact that the head
is lifted like this
and it's pointing in
a certain direction,
maybe it's a directional marker.
That's possible.
Now we have to figure out
where that's leading us to.
Maybe looking where
the head is looking
is the way you're
supposed to be going.
And that's what we should do.
I'll take Brad, and
we'll follow where
the head may be pointing to.
If it is pointing somewhere,
then we'll see where that goes.
We need to get more
information before we know
what this turtle is telling us.
One way or the other, we're
getting into this mountain.
I agree with you.
[metal detector whines]
NARRATOR: On the
mountain, Peter and Brad
continue searching along the
line of sight of the turtle
rock's head, looking
for any signs
that may lead to a
possible tunnel entrance.
Look at this.
NARRATOR: Peter and Brad have
discovered what they think
is a golden lily symbol and
called the rest of the team
down to determine if it
is a clue to the location
of Yamashita's treasure.
Wow.
That thing is pretty awesome.
It is hand-carved.
Is this anything that
you've ever seen before?
This could be a
golden lilies symbol
showing us the back door.
NARRATOR: Based on
Martin's research,
it is believed that Yamashita
strategically constructed
his tunnel systems with a
main front door entrance where
the treasure was loaded
and a smaller, more
concealed back door
where the Golden
Lily could access the tunnels.
So you're saying
that this symbol is
telling us about a back door?
Exactly.
When the Japanese and the
Golden Lily would come back,
they wouldn't want to use
the front door because they'd
have blasted it shut and loaded
up with all kinds of trip
wires, all this kind of stuff.
Because so many people saw.
Too many trucks coming
in and out, too many people
seeing what was going on.
So the imperial
family would have
needed a different way to
get into the treasure tunnel.
Exactly.
They needed a backdoor to get
in where not a lot of people
could see them.
- All right.
I don't think that it's going
to be that easy to find.
The Japanese were smart, so--
Exactly, so they probably
would've put cover stones in it
or put rocks together
to close that up
so they could get
in and out easy
and seal it back
all at one time.
This could very easily tell
us where the back door is.
I think, guys, all we need to
do is go back to this marker.
Everything so far has
led us to this point.
Grandpa tells us to go look
for the pyramid of rock.
We find that.
Holy crap.
Now that's a frickin' pyramid.
We find breach 6.
Holy cow.
We go up to the waterfalls.
We find the gorilla head.
That's the one, Manny.
We find the plunge pools.
We find the turtle.
This is the best thing
we've found so far.
Everything that
we've done so far
has brought us to
this one point--
to the back door.
This could be our entrance
into the mountain.
If we can find
it, we can open it.
Now I'm excited.
Today I'm excited.
Let's go find the back door.